As I said in the past several videos and
quizzes, there are a ton of mathematically
equivalent ways of writing any expression
we might have. For example, if I rearrange
the factors within any of the terms here,
or rearrange the order of the terms
themselves, or let's say, tack on a 0 at
the end. The value of the expression on
the right side of the equation doesn't
change. However, there are certain
convienient ways of writing expressions.
Ways that actually make them simplier to
deal with that we're going to want to use.
We call this process of rewriting
expressions; simplifing expressions. One
really useful tool that can help us start
to simplify and expression, or see if we
can simplify it any further, is to change
the order of the terms. We know that we're
allowed to do this because of the
communitive property of addition. So, how
could we do that here? Let's just
rearrange the terms on the right side of
this equation so that both terms
containing w are in the first two slots
and the two terms containing n are in the
last two slots. So please just type the
proper terms into the proper slots. These
smaller spaces are for plus or minus signs
but you can also type in as you see fit.